en algérie quatre cent mille ouvriers
doivent s'expatrier de façon régulière
pour aller chercher du travail ailleurs
ailleurs c'est à dire en france où le
marché du travail leur est ouvert comme
à tous les france
est-ce que vous quand tu es retourné en
algérie plus tard bah j'ai mes enfants
ils sont encore là et pour le moment
pour le moment je ne sente pas
exactement qu'est ce qu'on va faire
au moment où vous comptez continuer à
travailler en font un choix et un
principe
vos enfants sont avec vous oui ils sont
investis en france oui et vous pensez
vous pouvez élever votre famille bien
vous gagnez suffisamment votre vie ben
c'est justement si je gagne pas ma vie
je resterai pas ou est ce que vous irez
alors même si je ne gagne pas ma vie je
veux jouer dans un endroit où ce que je
peux regagner ma vie c'est injuste merci
l'industrie a besoin de leurs bras et
les attire par milliers chaque année
dans la métropole mais la plupart du
temps le relogement n'a pas été prévu
ainsi se sont créés dans les banlieues
près des centres industriels ces îlots
insalubres qui méritent bien leur triste
nom de bidonvilles à la fois de
déshonorant et désespérant comment vivre
là
ce problème d'intérêt général la
sécurité sociale la mise au rang de ses
préoccupations les plus pressantes 23
centres de ce genre simple mais doté du
confort moderne sont actuellement en
voie d'achèvement ou de réalisation
ainsi peut-on espérer que se réduire le
surpeuplement dégarni des hôtels et que
se videront les bidonvilles nuisible au
bon équilibre du corps social tout
entier
[Musique]
l'étiquette français musulmans
hier insidieusement à coller aux
indigènes d'algérie
répand désormais chez vous à une donnée
concrète l'objective je pense notamment
à vos jeunes concitoyens d'origine
algérienne
qui conserve l'espoir d'une conjonction
fait compte et non contradictoire
donc le statut de français
et leur attachement à leur patrie
d'origine il a fait une quarante ans au
cachot et parviennent en vie ce débat
âgées rappelle marie la famine gocycle a
longtemps que j'avais pas ailleurs
qu'elle avait dit farhad est à son
deuxième titre de l'actualité en début
d'après midi le convoi you never - situé
dans le jardin du mef éclore quant à jo
scholly
[Applaudissements]
alors
est-ce que tu as ton numéro de
d'immatriculation à l'armée
écoute tu sais pas où on s'est battu on
retrouve parce que moi je vais pas me
casser la tête il faut obligatoirement
ton numéro d'immatriculation c'est le
minimum si l'on tape à l'article 3
alors tu fais comme tu veux mais
les ventes au numéro d'immatriculation
il était sorti tes papiers militaires en
armes bizerte et papiers militaires tu
vas bien en avoir il trace quelque part
quand même même ton numéro
est pas tu me retrouve ça pour ce soir
et qu'il communique ça et tu dois aider
tu vas me signer la lettre
parce que sinon on attendra temps j'y
vais pour ma gueule et je te laisse
ok
d'accord
la prise de tête
[Musique]
on commence par bateau par des vagues
ont rarement sur un bateau
[Musique]
finalement ça devient une voiture à
l'exportation de laisser la basse et
vous à l'ucad à partir il ya toujours
une couchette mais là par exemple
salaire de commencer à ces blocs héroïne
et on cherchait des places etc qui
aujourd'hui j'ai eu des places que je
croyais pas possible une fois que vous
aurez tout payé je prendrai la
photocopie des trois billets pour les
avoir tués d'accord
ici ça me donne
19995 130 et si vous mangez avec ça plus
combien
ça m'est fait 22 1984 oui c'est un peu
plus de 880 4,50 c'est bon là
je suis là on stresse et la découpe et
moi
peut-être pas rodgers a commencé
ses pièces usagées c'est la boule dans
l'estomac dit
ouais ça fait bizarre
ouais mais moi j'ai le mien l'algérien
alors on est on est sûr
non le visa normalement il doit être sur
nos passeports amar
ben non moi je crois pas
il est à la maison je vais aller
vérifier tout de suite ouais
allô allô ouais ouais ouais c'est bon ça
fait 16 ans que je vais pas retourner
dans mon pays je me fais une joie de
retourner dans en algérie le fait une
joie de revoir toute la famille
de revoir la maison qu'on a là bas et
puis de de revoir tous les cousins et
cousines
et puis
j'ai l'impression que
l'on est en train de m'en empêcher de
vivre de vivre cet instant là quoi alors
pourquoi je sais pas mais
voilà là je passe mon temps à quoi en ce
moment je passe mon temps
on suit la préfecture
ont essayé d'obtenir des papiers pour
retourner dans mon pays quoi
on dit au départ en petit je suis
français je paye un visa donc
normalement je dois pas avoir problème
pour sortir d'un autre côté on me
demande ma carte militaire parce qu'on
considère comme algériens donc moi je
dis il faut qu'ils se positionnent
faudrait savoir quoi il faudrait
vraiment savoir ce qu'ils veulent au
minimum je pars stresse et arrivent
stressés et après tu sais même pas ce
qu'il peut se passer là-bas
parent
il faut quand même en vouloir j'ai quand
même endroit
je pense qu'une fois hors des quatre
heures à l'aéroport ah non
c'est une information qui vient d air
algérie c'est une information ce à titre
indicatif on n'est pas grave à titre
indicatif al amam un rooney c'est
l'information qui narre à titre
indicatif je ne me pose pas 90 ans et
sert à gérer ou cr france
se présente à l'hérault à les regards si
seuls les bagages enregistrés en bordure
des comptoirs d'enregistrement je
présente en ce moment quatre heures
avant l'heure de départ indiqué l'ue
sans allumer d'avatar parce que vous
avez quelques j'utilise quitté bien
évidemment avec jk rowling
oui c'est juste un charnier c'est pour
te dire pour contraire réagir et je vois
que relate une élève a justement tu l'as
fait réagir ouais parce qu'il ya
certains termes si le qui le gêne et
pourquoi pas si ça plait
je n'ai pas insulté mais est celle en
suède j'ai juste dit paul charié droit
mais lui ça guérit
[Musique]
tous les français
les petits beurres de banlieue les
petits beurres de banlieue car sait-on
terme ça les petits beurres de banlieue
je les connais pas l'équipe heures de
bonus tu les connais pas
[Musique]
c'est la france à plusieurs plans
les décidé de construire une maison avec
mon frère ali aïn benian
cela dure depuis 25 ans est ce qui fait
que cette année j'ai décidé d'aller avec
ma femme et mes enfants on voit ma
famille mais aussi continuer avec le peu
de moyens que j'ai eu cette construction
qui est dur car la construction
l'algérie est très très très cher
j'ai oublié de faire des trous dans ma
ceinture mais à deux mais ça fait
pas et faire des clous dans ma ceinture
aux 4 mai
mais vas-y c'est facile ajoie la chaux
explique moi pourquoi tu es fan je suis
pas venu pour deux choses premièrement
parce que j'ai faim des papiers
militaires d'accord oui mais
premièrement elle écoute un peu mis
d'accord hier à 2 2 après devient me
faire ça fait trois modes de vie digne
les lignes la première manche j'ai pas
mes papiers militaires deuxièmement
actuellement je suis dans une situation
au niveau du travail plus que délicate
et je suis en arrêt maladie d'accord et
quand tu es en arrêt maladie tu n'as pas
le droit de partir d'accord
c'est ben youssef c'est bon tu
sais moi viens au jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est quoi au jour d'aujourd'hui tpu mon
frère tu va
maintenant c'est fini de parler non
c'est fini est ce que tu veux mais je
vais t'emmener ou
à la dcri pour quoi faire si tu es
quelque chose a changé les dommages à
elle elle dit je m'en vais attends tu
vas à vitré fait honneur à y bien je
vais t'emmener parce qu'il faut que je
passe chez moi je changeais à 28,28 même
si ce moment
là il y avait 40 parce que vitry ferme
or il est très ferme
mais bon
c'est tellement ça
et pourquoi cuche est aussi ça va pas
lancer c'est pas moi ça me
va
[Musique]
aller la voir à mal et on en dise mon
attention qu'on vive attention
tu conduis je t'en prie attention
doit-on faire mais l'ex attention voilà
un très beau pays du monde
[Musique]
il
cette gamme
john thys âgées je dirai pas ce que tu
la loire à vincennes
soit rodin
la thématique match là je vous dis tout
net être là alors je voudrais calais il
va là bas on me l'a connaît bien avec
lui rien mais il reconnaît aimer a
longtemps que ça pas venir quelqu'un
d'autre part il reconnaît encore alors
voilà je vous dis absolument que même si
un taxi avait pour la nuit
en laurent le fait il n'y a pas
d'accord ouais je t'embrasse
une heure tout seul 3h 4h du matin par
cinq
arrivées quoi
[Musique]
en immigration et du haut
faites juste auquel dépendance les
caisses de l'état étaient vides y avait
pas de travail toujours pensé vivre avec
nos enfants et en retour avec osant
aujourd'hui je suis à plus de la 35e
année et la situation n'est toujours pas
réglée il croit que 80% des enfants
algériens question je crois que on
perdra on perdra au change
ouais ça va aller voir of bahrain kenya
ça va bien a galéré à la galére dans le
canton on a galéré c'est la croisière
s'amuse pas en vrai c'est appeler si on
peut là dans la journée au thème et nous
notre maison et la
dernière la partie
à droite là
salade que tu vas à droite
ça la
[Musique]
personne
qu'est ce que justement savoir
[Applaudissements]
ce retour au pays
c'est pour donner une image à mes
enfants et pour dire voilà ce que je
peux vous laisser est ce que je souhaite
que vous
continuez à faire ce que j'ai commencé
[Musique]
on arrive après 20 ans aura fini pialat
dans loulou
semaine
5 tonnes pourquoi pas toujours pas dit
qu'il faudrait plein stade rouennais est
là donc c'est ça qu'il faut aussi il
faut donner des
directives
quand on joue
donc afrique que tu as vu la danse qui
sont arrivés
scor est longue
mais le message
ces deux-là succès sur la suède
baj
de fait
[Musique]
regard d'électricité verte il reste il a
amené des prises exprès pour faire
l'électricité là c'est anormal qu'on
arrivait qu'on peut ce même pas se poser
mais on peut se poser du camping là on
fait pas de camping tu peux dormir chez
tonton c'est pas le problème je veux pas
tant mieux chez les hommes roger dormir
chez moi oui mais tu vas dormir chez toi
tu sais on va la faire on va passer un
coup de peinture on va mettre
l'électricité on va mettre les toilettes
là pendant le mois et va ça va bien se
passer et en tombant l'ami d'habiter là
bas ou d'habiter là il avait toujours
moi
de
ton tour de te faire
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps
qu'on
en dise un barrage
youssef il devait venir mais des
problèmes de papiers et de travail ou
qui n'a pas plu à des commandements des
revenus qui a remarqué mon père est
malgré tout on est chez nous
3 c'est la plus grande série crj
et une peut pas laisser travailler
maintenant il veut pas c'est pas mieux
quel travail qu'elle ramène un peu
d'argent à ma sauce comme l'a dit le
médecin
m'a dit c'est comme ça mais incroyable
je coupe mon
nous voir la maison
et fils
alors là il faut que tu parles à leur
père
[Rires]
on va y aller
mais il nous aurait
fait qu'elle profite elle au bord de la
mer si ça marche assez bien qu'on vous
ça je sais je vais pas comparer le fait
d'être en france elle fait l'algérie
mais il faut qu'ils aient un juste
milieu un minimum quand j'ai vu tout on
m'a dit qu'à la fin de non-recevoir lève
et que ses soeurs ses filles elles ont
même pas le droit de mettre le nez
dehors le nez bien aller faire une
course ne voit jamais mais attends moi
ça me met hors de moi je peux pas rester
comme ça sans rien dire j'ai pas
possible vraiment il devenu très dur
avec elle un
m
j'ai dit heureusement qu'ils se marient
les trois premières bruit
par moi aussi j'ai le droit de dire ce
que j'ai à la marée pour elle alors si
elle est là pas la parole
n'est ce pas parlé on la laisse pas
parler de toi tu as un peu de fumée dans
olé mais méritée après alors si moi je
n'ai pas proposé je suis désolé si moi
je n'ai pas proposé ainsi à devenir
qu'est ce qui lui aurait proposé de
roberta bush pour lui demander mais pas
en france il met le bras ballants et pas
qu'aux en france ou connaissances et la
lunella anglais milan là mais rien
d'autre il est là
à cahors
on verra c'est sympa
très bien ça te plaît
sa promesse en tout genre oui
au royaume
jeudi pas moins un petit peu quand même
pas vous vous proposez moi aujourd'hui
si un immigré venu en algérie devenir un
vrai mari compétences et d'abord la vie
autrement mais trois trophées majeurs et
qui lui aussi
pu dire que c'est bon
pour casser la croûte
c'est sûr que ça doit pas être évident
quand
vous sortez un petit peu vous êtes un
peuple libre
et bien sûr
si tu montes tu sors peu twin et tu vois
tout temps l'entourage n'est pas mais ça
sert à quoi
il n'est pas la santé
[Musique]
shi
v
ça c'est mon rôle c'est plus vivant
parce que c'est pas possible
besser
1 oui il rigole
mais ce petit gars est lui
équipé
pour la
route vers sa maman dans la salle à
[Musique]
2,3
pourquoi tant de promesses
non on n'a pas fait non non moi j'ai
des parfums dans la beauté plein dans sa
peau nette et une bonne coupe de tissus
sais pas c'est pas évident à
quillan un foulard à quelqu'un et puis
là tu lui en a et plus tôt et pas se
fâcher alors on essaye d'équilibrer la
chose il a tellement
les gens ma famille que j'ai pas vu
pendant deux ou trois ans alors si tu
leur donnes qu'un
qu'un foulard ou cas machin tu restes
heures
je crois que ça la moitié des fringues
que j'avais ça va rien ça va commencer
on est à la maison on est chef chez ton
père chez nous chez son oncle avec ses
enfants sa femme
et voilà on est bien question tu veux tu
parles accomplissent way allez bon
restant brassens à lui nous c'est le ton
j'ai ici à ces travaux on est là c'est
de la bombe atomique
il hésite on
allait coûter cher
celui qui paye moi aussi je paye mes
toiles au
fait qu'elle passe le bonjour malika
voitures des vertueux tu regardes pas
que tu pas venu un peu hein on s'amuse
un peu moins bien ils s'amusent moi non
mais nos frères malek ta soeur ta soeur
bon allez je t'embrasse embrasse tout le
monde aussi allez salut à voir m ce
dimanche
je vais regarder
ça va ce si
différent du travail qu'elle ramène un
peu d'argent non pourquoi c'est ça que
moi c'est ça que je suis papa quel
travail
travailler ses fans
non maintenant c'est pas une question de
travail peut travailler pour elle mais
elle de travail à la maison s'ils
pourraient vous voulez marcher ça il
faut des marchés
il ya beaucoup de gens qui travaillent
chez eux sans s'en sortir
moi je vais envoyer mon et puis il va
faire d'eux
l'espagne pays tu vas tu apprends
modélisme la peinture que c'est ce que
tu veux mais pour travailler à l'amour
mais a gardé vous avez besoin que zizou
il n'avait guère
vous n'êtes pas démissionner pour vous
arrêter de travailler maintenant c'est
parce qu'elle ne savait pas
il faut quand même il faut bien qu est
ce qui ramène à l'argent moi ce qui me
désole le plus c'est qu'on pense au fait
d'être dans la misère dans la misère
et ne pas laisser travailler les femmes
les eaux ne travaille pas et dans la
misère vous crever de faim il ya les
jeux ça année sinon beau ça nous met
dans une révolte ou le pantalon en
mousseline au scratch qui nous empêche
de faire certaines choses ce sont les
gens
moi si on est en même temps ça revient
au même parce que quand on n'aime pas
en touchant l'eau
minérale et ce n'est pas moi je le sais
mais les gens ne savent pas réagi mais
trop clean sheet regard des chiffres
soral va sortir avec son cousin c'est
son cousin et je ne peux pas le
confiance en les confinant 100 m elle
peut sortir seule main
même si je l'envoie discuter avec
quelqu'un d'autre j'ai confiance en lui
mais les gens est ce qu'il le semble
pourquoi c'est si important pour les
gens
mais parce qu'après je sais que tu m'as
vu que mal considéré
ça découle de plage ans déjà des cours
de peinture le premier la plage elle
était tellement sale unis dans l'eau jal
a besoin de 5 0 et ben si c'est la
première quand elle va à la mer avec des
bûches qu'il faut laisser des
représentants des sept îles h et bien on
va la nourrir il ya un petit exemple
cette heure mon ami de la déco pas
ses copains partout où ils vont y voir
sa soeur vous êtes une voix et sa soeur
nous voilà point qu'ils ont pu ainsi
avaya à chéraga et son but aux siens
alors que c'est faux alors que c'est
faux
parfois qu'ils ne voient pas leurs
soeurs qui s'entiche à boufarik qui
s'établit dans ces désagréments et c'est
la vérité c'est la vérité qui est ce que
tu vas croire les voisins ta famille qui
est ce que tu vas fois comme ma famille
mais
toujours en tout qui va supposer la
gestion de ses émotions et je sais qu'il
faut que tu fasses que pas de comprendre
te dire mais c'est ma famille ou à
résoudre le voisin qui est derrière qui
croyait bien parce qu'il a envie croire
rmc des années d'inhibition forget s'est
terminée sans les charges qui commençait
bien sûr mais vous commencez les c'est
tout doucement sépare justement un
dialogue comme ça je crois que tu peux
arriver et moi je comprends parfaitement
sa position ici j'arrive à comprendre
comment il réagit me peu témoin se
plaint assia parce que je sais qu'elle a
envie c'est pas moi je l'accepterais pas
parce que moi j'ai été éduqué en france
et humains apparemment moi je mets un
fait je comprends ce qui veut dire je le
comprends parfaitement mais c'est pas ça
veut pas dire que je les accepte je le
comprends je comprends qu'il ait pas
envie que sa soeur elles sortent parce
qu'il a peur parce qu'on est dans un
village parce que les gens parlent par
an les gens parler bah tout le monde ait
connu ici tout le monde moi j'arrive
parfaitement à le comprendre mais ça ne
veut pas dire que je n'accepte moi je
l'accepterais pas parce que moi je suis
né en france parce que moi j'ai vécu en
france parce que mon frère il laissera
faire tout ce que j'aurais envie de
faire parce que m
[Musique]
pourrait pas oublier votre religion ça
c'est paris c'est pas qui pourra nous
aussi
de toute façon tu auras une religion
quel quelle soit
moi que tu sois et matin à lorient
du moment que tu crois que tu n'es pas
ti pas besoin de faire une prière ou
bien peu pour être bien dans ma peau
je crois que dans les moments difficiles
tu appelles dieu va écouter dans les
moments difficiles jamais vraiment
été bien loin des moments difficiles où
tu as fait radieux attend secours qui
est à plaindre à dieu atd tu as fait
radieux et du phrasé prière
ça ne concerne que toi je pensais un peu
toi c'est que tu connais pas c'est pour
ça que je sais que c'est pas tout c'est
qu'elle soit environ catholiques de
toute religion quelles sont les accepte
pas parce que c'est perso tu peux pas
obliger les gens à prendre à gages de
chance que tu ne ressens rien c'est
personnel si tu te tu as ta façon de moi
s'il vous disent les plaies parce que je
me sens bien besoin du bouddhisme ouais
ben ouais mais je veux pas qu'on oublie
gerra mais personne ne t'oblige c'est ce
que j'aime dans ma famille seront jamais
obligée à personne une personne ne
souhaite oblige il t'oblige à à
pratiquer une religion que tu es nous
vaudra pas un mais deux secrétaires se
dit que généreuse moi oui je t'ai dit tu
vois pratiquer une religion une
quelconque religion chien du parquet
c'est l'islam mais je sais que tu
reviendrais un jour
les chercheurs savent attaquer nous
sommes des gens car je vous approchez
soient apportées des caroff des cadres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
permettre peut sentir
dans la course peut sortir des
murs des murs 3000 quatre ans qu'à sa
tête sur les murs c'est ok ce qu'on peut
faire rien c'est tatiana marc elle veut
partir que les jours à la plage oui mais
à la raison alors à mais là c'est la
raison enfin un petit
travail le travail que le travail dans
le taxi
sauf stable est passé c'est maintenant
ma table
l'algérie a alors rien changé il est
devenu un corps pire qu'avant pire tabor
alors la vl de très cher aux errements
des gens ne mangent pas les pauvres les
enfants surtout ne mange pas ils ont pas
les moyens de manger il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas le droit de manger que s'il
gagne 15 millions par mois c'est quoi
améliore pas moi c'est me feront de la
france on vous fait un million par mois
il ya 1 2 4 5 6 7 8 qu'est ce qui va
leur nombre même du pain c'est qu'ils
n'arrivent pas leur donner du pain sec
comme ça qui va acheter du pain 400
bloqués il peut pas arriver allons
donner puisqu'il n'ya pas de ya pas de
travail il n'y a pas d'argent il
apparaît l'eau vient après trois jours
quatre jours et on est en plein été on
n'est pas un hiver même en hiver on doit
avoir de l'eau s'est fait chaud dans
savez on doit prendre dans la ville par
terre et c'est chaud c'est quoi ça même
pas d'eau un jour oui un jour non il ya
de l'eau ou jour ya pas deux trois jours
ya pas deux vient une fois deux heures
la nuit c'est pas la nuit quand on fait
le ménage un joueur la voie d'eau à la
20 jours il comprend pourquoi le pouvoir
et que récente de long 1
[Musique]
il
ou pas
[Musique]
amar embrasse attendent
certes la même chose
mon père si son nom sa cousine et frère
voilà c'est fait c'est fait des mariages
consanguins mais non
[Musique]
avant de faire le voyage avec mes
enfants je tenais à cette couleur qui ne
sache qui le voyaient et ça c'était
important pour moi de leur montrer où
est son intérêt
nos parents
nos vieux parents ou grand père leur
mère puis c'est important pour la
mémoire
[Musique]
alors là
je commence par
son ampleur
[Musique]
oui
ok mais
je garde la pure et
naturelle plus rapide mais tu te croire
ou en france ou quoi ici aussi les nanas
orange et je préfère sa
boîte
de terre
en
au mama mama mama
oh mon dieu mais comment on vit à cette
époque comme on dit sans de l'eau sans
rien elle de ce que je t'ai vu ouais moi
aussi je suis arrivé
il était un peu d'eau
on a pareillement brut
[Musique]
c'était une place qui était magnifique
pour les villageois à pornichet donné
les gens dans l'après-midi fin d'après
midi les familles des 100 d'ici là alors
ils avaient des intérêts des quatre à
oued et rameau si tu passais la crau
discipline yachts et d'une passé tout
l'après-midi dans sept mois
ça c'est drôle anémique un niveau groupe
l'agefi en plus de ça c'est que baignade
interdite il ya un policier a connu
jeune qui vient interdit réellement la
bm parce que ces enfants là quand il
tombe malade ou est ce qu'ils vont se
soigner qui déçoit
[Applaudissements]
mazigh wad à 12
le baladi
nous serons à l'ado sifflets mois
bel et bien aux toiles comment tout le
parc cette révolte n'est pas parce qu'on
vient envir de l'immigration du machin
non c'est pas ça c'est parce que je suis
né ici et je connais et
j'aime j'aime j'aime mon village et
j'aime en plus donc n'importe quel type
qui sont issus
j'aime bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà des roches
c'est sage et 3g
je donne hélas
[Applaudissements]
l'agent du rhum a été dépendant des gens
pour sortir tu peux pas sortir ta leur
short qu'une seule s'il n'ya pas 100 m
kim ont accosté n'a pas un thème suivant
plus tu vois tu obligé de prendre une
pierre hantaï pour leur montrer que de
se défendre que tu vas leur lancée comme
des chiens le ccd chiens chats et des
chiens après toi ils n'ont jamais vu une
nana marcher tout seul jamais ça qui
m'énerve fait était dans n'importe
quelle ville en europe ou même en
tunisie ne serait-ce qu'en tunisie t as
c'est quoi la tunisie c'est à une heure
d'avion d'ici même pas en tunisie je
marche dans la rue je vais boire un coup
tout seul qui me fait pas emmerdé comme
je me fais emmerder ici du coup ça
t'oblige à rester chez toi à faire comme
toutes les filles qui sont ici à rester
chez toi et à fermer ta bouche parce que
tu peux rien dire d'autre voilà un mois
ça mais rien de tout ça j'ai fait mon
possible pour malade et je me suis
adapté j'ai dit ok d'accord serait-ce
trois semaines trois semaines dans un
enfin dans une vie ça passe ça passe
très bien voilà preuve gérant ce voyage
j'ai annoncé mon départ d'une fenêtre
que je peux parler serait pour nous
tu m'énerves ici même
tous mes nerfs face
ils font leur possible pour proposer
travers non c'est pas ça c'est
que tu peux rien faire téter compris
c'est moi je fais que de monter
descendre nous fait descendre des sommes
montés des andes
je crois que 40 ans après et pendant ce
couac elle mais encore loin du pouvoir
de ce qu'on vient on s'attendait
je suis déçu du fait que mes enfants
sont déçus c'est vrai que moi je
m'adapte ce que je suis de ces gens là
et même s'il manque quelque chose je
mets
aux comptes qui dit rêver de la fatalité
c'est ça ils vont nettoyer ça avec les
fous descendre mois il faut des
centaines et des centaines de milles
d'eau pour nettoyer ta
regard-là
duquel que ça fait six mois qu'ils
louaient haschisch
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je met un peu de son mode histoire de
journée
[Musique]
et pourquoi pas pourquoi les ouvriers
un paquet d'argent de la vrt
mais à
partir de votre souris de partir en
vacances
[Musique]
aïe aïe la dernière ici regarde là comme
si des livres à sa gueule sur sa
province alors nous on te paye l'argent
est fourni on va faire les autres
[Musique]
où
djouzi comme rajhi de bol je vous
alors il faut pas chercher à comprendre
voilà les vous voulez qu'on lui cherche
à comprendre quand même on peut pas olé
on est réprimée ont pas parlé je peux
pas parler
si tu peux
[Musique]
il voit
tu pars dans lui on l'espère tu parles
et on dit la raison il n'y a pas de
justice sociale
le produit
sur qui confia y apporte rien par l'état
ne prend pas en charge son corps
c'est un peu dur
et on
est
pouvoir
lamiraux terre et la lune
ici pas de l'ouganda
n'y a pas d'histoire ils ont pas ils ont
pas ils ont pas
sujet l'histoire n'ont pas d'histoire on
sait pas c'est que c'est pas bien et ne
joue pas et c'est parti
c'est dû à quoi c'est dû à tort et ben
si tu as
à tous les gouvernements
qui se sont succédé ici constituent des
et pour ça rien qu'à eux pensant que
leurs familles alors en génie tueur mais
je veux aussi dire qu'en france il ya
aussi des problèmes de vue un pic n'a
pas de problème ce n'est pas un pays
largement crash et ça ça va on a compris
on le sait mais ici c'est pas des
premières c'est pas des propos c'est
quelqu'un de
trop ou trop
il passait des choses a argumenté
hors alimentation pouvoir c'est
si ces marchés ça va marcher
oh
aujourd'hui on
question
dimanche
parce qu'on remords qu'il ya deux
catégories 10 millions
franchement nombre bien ceux qui
viennent ici
l'impression qui sont nostalgiques qu'on
me dit
vienne parce que il ressent encore
fraternité saint pie x on a bien avec
leurs cousins et tout ce qu'ils peuvent
voir derrière mini vont pas venir
la deuxième catégorie d'immigrés et on
ne ressent plus d'heures qu'ils nous
voient comme des
et comme des indigènes pour des gens
quand des gens et
sous développés
sous sous alimentés
les gens de deuxième classe il vient ni
frime avec leurs fringues avec leurs
bagnoles et tout en laissant en laissant
que c'est physique du matériel il ne
s'est pas vrai que c'est pas parce qu'on
vous aime quand on est candidat mais un
seul a bien décrit à deux générations
donc à celle de mon père qui reviennent
qui sont nostalgiques
qui ont le pays dans leur coeur ils ont
grandi là ils ont vécu là ils ont donné
à l'algérie comme jamais il aurait donné
un autre pays ils n'ont pas donné aux
par la france et c'est là qu'ils veulent
finir leur vie et à cette nouvelle
génération de jeunes qui viennent moins
chez un peu comme mon père je suis venu
très souvent quand j'étais jeune
j'aime l'algérie tu vas c'est un truc
qui mais qui au fond de moi
[Rires]
tu sais de prendre des migraines elle
que je vais dire entre deux chaises
il a ses racines qui ressortent tu vois
hélas son pays d'accueil qui qu'il
accepte mais semble vraiment l'accepter
il accepte que s'il a une situation que
s'il a quelque chose de concret de
matériel comme tu dis tu vas et ça ça
c'est une mentalité que les immigrés les
fils d'immigrés ont pris parce qu'ils
sont nés comme des français moi je suis
né en france tu vois ce que je veux dire
je vis à l'européenne je m'en cache pas
et
je trouve que justement il ya un fossé
tu vas en france c'est trop et en
algérie c'est pas assez je pense que les
mlg dormir beaucoup plus davantage pour
essayer de changer un peu la mentalité
on a besoin d'eux parce que si on veut
changer
il faut qu'on sorte on se rend elle pas
on n'est pas chez soi lance l'ont
tellement quatre murs barreaux et tout
ça on a besoin de migrer pour les aider
c'est vrai t'as plus de la paix
touristes il ya plus de coopérer
même si normalement ils sont exportés et
où tu peux pas les approcher on n'est
plus en contact avec eux et ce qui est
important que les sociétés une société
c'est important qu est ce qu elle se
frotte à d'autres à d'autres
civilisations d'autres cultures et aux
opprimés nous les seuls avec qui on est
encore taxer les immigrés
jo diouf faisait pas
trop
[Musique]
ziza
[Applaudissements]
ça
suite aux réactions de soutien
pression
de vapeur du pôle voilà
il
ah
bon
pas de chance
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes parti en savoir beaucoup de
choses en selle c'est ma vie c'est pour
ainsi dire j'ai travaillé à l'étranger
mais ma vie ici c'est à dire même malgré
que je je travaillais dans un pays qui
n'était pas le mien mais qui m'a donné
de quoi vivre de quoi
subvenir à ma famille mais je crois que
c'est mme c c'est maintenant si
ça vous êtes là vous êtes euros
on a l'habitude ashton est mariée vous
avez une maison c'est
possible et elle retrouva ne trouvera
jamais c'est pas trouveront jamais mes
enfants c'est une fille elle sort elle
n'existe pas des filles et les garçons
qui nous sommes j'ai offert une attaque
quand même à alger même pas
si
elle serait officielle jeu pour le
mondial il valide seulement un mois
d'août pour une femme divorcée
[Musique]
et l'âme il est pas mal jamais
non
ici
même à moi
encore et continuent ils ont par les
décisions prises ou à la mosquée
oum
[Musique]
al charia et ça t'arrive est il un
esprit
étroit tromper 3 et puis plus d'être à
sa fin plus il a aidé
la raison malheureusement
je parle en connaissance de cause
bon avant je disais sa
vie quand tu devrais pas
et maintenant plus que tu me disais j'ai
donc essayé d'en
mais capte tap a essayé de reprendre un
travail en insistant qui peut en géant
je suis avec 12 soit parce que si c'est
à dire je me demande d'une façon les
sauveurs
je me poserai des
matinées
doucement des seychelles et une
quinzaine de voitures continuent
oui mais impossible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la
police
avait procédé
ancien
la direction se voter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir
un mille mètres d'altitude avec deux
soirs 2200 km heure le vol supersonique
sera l'avenir du transport a
remonté les hippies l'année passée
[Musique]
est ce que tu peux rester dans ce temps
leur non il faut pas que tu fais ça tu
sais j'en ai fait en a pour tout le
monde a droit ou qu'il est toi tu bosses
maelle et tu vois les 48 heures la 48
heures on est restés plus de 25% au
corps à ses 25 ans avec nous ça lui
laissera les lots divers nous envoyons
des messages mais un nouvel ami station
aussi pour l'eau pour eux
je connais bien depuis dix ans c'est à
dire je suis venu ya dix ans un mondiale
elle n'a pas changé d'un gramme de gras
mais n'a pas changé et c'est ce qui se
passe oui le monde de se révolter
jamais que
si on peut se rendre au poste d'avant
ouais je te suis derrière qui s'annonce
tranquille personne n'a pas laissé les
femmes on est parfaitement apte à soeur
marie cas on est passé par là tu en es
passé il y avait mon âme est démontable
des ordures de montal des sables
doublement
pourquoi il a ça dans ce pays qui était
très très très très riche qui avait bon
la france lui devrait il devrait faire
il devrait faire le maximum des chiffons
et rêvions les français qui s'était pas
assurée car c'est le premier j'avais la
panique a passionné
les conditions
là
voilà avance à dos que maggie
encore
à bientôt
regarde maman que ce faire
mais sa vie n'est
rien pour toi services et de louer pas
de l'osce et de la boue
avant qui codent tu vas où avec vous tu
viens avec nous je croyais que tu restes
et voilà tu vas aller aux toilettes
là-bas
oui
mais s'ils cherchent des achats de
chaufferie est vrai les quêtes
[Musique]
oui
mais ce bon appétit voici les
informations concernant la vie de notre
vol
pour ma maison ça me fait vraiment quand
je me rappelle j'ai l'âme je vous jure
que mel et que j'ai les larmes dans les
yeux quand je me rappelle que ma maison
n'est pas en quoi
ça
sert à
ça viendra quand on serait vieux quand
je serai plus vieille je peux plus je
peux pas profiter après c'est fini
comment voulez vous je profite après un
est dans la maison où elles seraient
elles seraient construites ça fait
depuis qu'on a commencé depuis 80 ans on
serait resté peut-être cinq ans pour la
faire
15 ans pourquoi 15 ans je m'habitue
dedans chaque année je te jure chacun
lit je viens mes enfants il était encore
petit est venu ici pour apprendre la vie
de l'algérie pour prendre l'avis 6,6 et
c'est la maison les terres et elle était
faite tu comprends
problème situation
non c'est la famille
aujourd'hui on peut rien faire qui est
toujours accompagné de jets de quoi t'es
pas de nom de départ photo nous la
maison
pas d'eau pendant cinq jours la seule
soirée bien qu'on n'a pas assisté hier
dans un hôtel
cinq étoiles e6 et on s'est éclaté
en algérie est éclatée droit
[Musique]
beaucoup je veux être